[Applause]
[Music]
well the future is here and Raven Symone
is totally wiped up yep that's me
the 34 year old actress revealed on
Instagram Thursday that she and her lady
love Miranda Maday are officially
married
Raven first teased the news posting a
photo of this wineglass writing in the
caption so something happened this week
that has changed my life for the better
then she shared this smiley pick with
her bride and confirmed the good news
quote I got married to a woman who
understands me from trigger to joy from
breakfast to midnight snack from stage
to home I love you mrs. Pearman Maday
the actress also posted this photo of
the outside of a house leading fans to
believe they had a small celebration at
home she thanked everyone who helped
plan the soiree and those who understand
why they had to keep it small amid the
corona virus pandemic Raven and Miranda
were beaming on their big day they
shared some snaps on their social media
pages raven rock tall black while
Miranda wore all white including a veil
and their celeb house wasted no time
sending a couple love in the comments
Ravens Cheetah Girls co-star Adrienne
Houghton wrote in all caps
congratulations
Raven replied it took me forever but I'm
in the club now Raven and I have kept a
great relationship
I love Raven today I mean it's literally
chuchi and bubbles for life and white
fellow Cheetah Girls Sabrina Bryan who's
expecting her first child wished the
pair so much love and despite their ups
and downs Keeley Williams also commented
writing quote wishing you both a
lifetime of love joy and laughter like
well I appreciate that sweetheart and I
release any pain towards you that I have
and I can't sit there and delete it
other celebs who shared their congrats
todrick Hall Lala
Anthony Bow Wow Yvette Nicole Brown
danielle fishel and fellow Disney
Channel star
christy carlson romano ET video-chatted
with Raven from home in April
even during lockdown Raven was busy
releasing new music
[Music]
if you had to describe miss Raven it
what would you say no say she's a 34
year old human who has had many
successes in her life and who was able
to stand in front of you and be
comfortable in her own skin
finally
[Music]